WE'RE GOING TO BREAK IN HERE AND
GO LIVE TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HEADING TO THE
ROSE GARDEN.
GETTING A LOT OF APPLAUSE AS
HE'S NOW FINALLY OUT OF
ISOLATION.
HAS TESTED NEGATIVE FOR COVID.
LET'S LISTEN TO THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
♪
>> AS I WAS WALKING OUT, I
THOUGHT I HEARD A RUMBLING IN MY
STAFF SAYING, "OH, HE'S BACK."
THANKS FOR STICKING AROUND.
HELLO, EVERYONE.
I'VE JUST TESTED NEGATIVE FOR
COVID-19 AFTER ISOLATING FORK
FIVE DAYS.
[ CHEERS ]
THANKFULLY I'LL BE ABLE TO WORK
IN PERSONME.
I WANT TO THANK YOU YOU FORGOTT.
I WANT TO THANK THE MEDICAL TEAMOR
FOR THE INCREDIBLE CARE THEY
GAVE ME.
FORTUNATELY, GOD THANKFULLY, GOD
WILLING, MY SYMPTOMS WERE MILD.
MY RECOVERY WAS QUICK, AND I'M
FEELING GREAT.
THE ENTIRE TIME I IN ISOLATION I
WAS ABLE TO WORK, TO CARRY OUT
THE DUTIES OF THE OFFICE AND
WITHOUT ANY INTERRUPTION.
IT'S A REAL STATEMENT WHERE WE
ARE IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
COVID-19.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE -- WE ARE FACING
A NEW VARIANT, THE BA.5 VARIANT.
A VERY TRANSMISSIBLE VERSION OF
OMICRON VARIANT WE SAW HERE THIS
PAST WINTER.
IN FACT, THIS NEW VARIANT THAT
INFECTED ME IS GETTING A LOT OF
PEOPLE INFECTED ALL AROUND THE
WORLD, NOT JUST HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WE SHOULD TAKE PRECAUTIONS TO
TRY TO SLOW THE SPREAD OF THIS
VIRUS.
MY ADMINISTRATION HAS MADE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO IMPROVE VENTILATION
IN OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR PUBLIC
BUILDINGS.
WE'VE MADE TESTS WIDELY
AVAILABLE SO YOU CAN TAKE ONE
BEFORE ATTENDING A LARGE INDOOR
GATHERING OR VISITING WITH
HIGH-RISK INDIVIDUALS.
WE'VE MADE HIGH-QUALITY MASKS
AVAILABLE FOR FREE.
SO YOU SHOULD CONSIDER WEARING A
MASK WHEN YOU'RE IN A CROWDED
INDOOR PUBLIC PLACE.
THESE PRECAUTIONS ADD AN EXTRA
LAYER OF PROTECTION FOR YOU AND
FOR THOSE AROUND YOU.
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT BA.5
MEANS MANY OF US ARE STILL GOING
TO GET COVID EVEN IF WE TAKE THE
PRECAUTIONS.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE'RE DOING
ANYTHING WRONG.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS COVID IS
STILL WITH US AS IT HAS BEEN FOR
2.5 YEARS.
BUT OUR FIGHT AGAINST COVID IS
MAKING A HUGE DIFFERENCE.
WHAT'S DIFFERENT NOW IS OUR
ABILITY TO PROTECT OURSELVES
FROM SERIOUS ILLNESS DUE TO
COVID.
IN FACT, THAT'S RADICALLY
DIFFERENT TODAY THAN IT WAS JUST
A YEAR AGO.
COVID ISN'T GONE, BUT EVEN WITH
CASES CLIMBING IN THIS COUNTRY,
COVID DEATHS ARE DOWN NEARLY
90%, AND WHEN I TOOK OFFICE,
THAT'S 90% DIFFERENCE FROM TODAY
AND WHEN I TOOK OFFICE.
THAT'S WHAT'S NEW.
THAT'S WHAT'S NEW IN COVID
RESPONSE.
DIFFERENT FROM WHERE WE WERE
JUST A YEAR AGO.
EVEN IF COVID -- EVEN IF YOU GET
COVID, YOU CAN AVOID WINDING UP
WITH A SEVERE CASE.
YOU CAN NOW PREVENT MOST COVID
DEATHS, AND THAT'S BECAUSE THREE
FREE TOOLS MY ADMINISTRATION HAS
INVESTED IN AND DISTRIBUTED THIS
PAST YEAR -- BOOSTER SHOTS,
AT-HOME TESTS, EASY-TO-USE,
EFFECTIVE TREATMENTS.
WE'VE GOT THROUGH COVID WITH NO
FEAR -- I GOT THROUGH IT WITH NO
FEAR.
A VERY MILD DISCOMFORT BECAUSE
OF THESE ESSENTIALS, LIFESAVING
TOOLS.
AND GUESS WHAT -- I WANT TO
REMIND EVERYBODY, THEY ARE FREE.
THEY ARE CONVENIENT, AND THEY
ARE SAFE, AND THEY WORK.
FIRST, BOOSTER SHOTS.
THEY WEREN'T AVAILABLE A YEAR
AGO.
THEY ARE NOW EVERYWHERE.
EVERY PERSON AGED 5 AND OVER
SHOULD GET A BOOSTER SHOT.
IF YOU'RE OVER 50 YEARS OLD, YOU
SHOULD GET TWO BOOSTER SHOTS.
I DID, AND IF YOU HAVE YOUR
BOOSTERS, ONE IF YOU'RE UNDER
50, TWO IT YOU'RE OVER 50, YOUR
ODDS OF GETTING SEVERELY ILL
FROM COVID ARE VERY, VERY LOW.
EVEN OLDER AMERICANS ARE VERY
UNLIKELY TO GET SEVERE COVID IF
THEY HAVE TWO BOOSTER SHOTS.
MOST COVID DEATHS ARE AMONG
THOSE WHO ARE NOT UP TO DATE ON
THEIR SHOTS, THEIR COVID
VACCINATIONS.
SO IF YOU'RE OVER 50 AND YOU
HAVEN'T GOTTEN A BOOSTER SHOT
THIS YEAR, GO GET ONE RIGHT
AWAY.
GO TO COVID.GOV, TYPE IN YOUR
ZIP CODE, AND FIND A PLACE WHERE
YOU CAN GET A BOOSTER SHOT FOR
FREE.
USUALLY AT A SITE THAT'S LESS
THAN FIVE MILES FROM YOUR HOME.
SECOND, AT-HOME TESTS.
A YEAR AGO AT-HOME TESTS WERE
RARE AND EXPENSIVE.
M
NOW EVERYONE IN AMERICA CAN GET
THEM FOR TFREE SHIPPED TO THEIR
DOOR, SHIPPED TO THEIR DOOR.
THERE'S NO EXCUSE.
GO TO COVID.GOV AND ORDER
AT-HOME TESTS FOR FREE.
TESTING TO FIND OUT IF YOUR
SYMPTOMS MEAN YOU HAVE COVID IS
CRITICAL IN GETTING TREATMENT
QUICKLY.
THIRD, TREATMENTS.
IF YOU TEST POSITIVE, YOU HAVE A
NEW POWERFUL -- WE HAVE A NEW
POWERFUL TREATMENT CALLED
PAXLOVID.
IT WASN'T AVAILABLE A YEAR AGO.
IT'S NOW -- IT'S A PILL, AND NOW
YOU CAN TAKE THESE PILLS AT
HOME.
YOU CAN GET THEM FOR FREE AT
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF LOCAL DRUG
STORES AROUND THE COUNTRY.
THE FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION, THE FDA, EVEN
PUT IN A SPECIAL RULE SO MANY
PHARMACISTS CAN PRESCRIBE THESE
-- THIS PARTICULAR DRUG.
SO YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE TO GO TO
THE DOCTOR TO GET A
PRESCRIPTION.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS HAVE USED
PAXLOVID.
I TELL YOU WHAT -- I THINK IT'S
-- I USED IT -- PAXLOVID
INCLUDING ME.
THIS LIFESAVING DRUG REDUCES
RISKS OF HOSPITALIZATION AND
DEATH FROM COVID-19 BY ABOUT
90%.
AGAIN, IT'S FREE, SAFE, AND EASY
TO TAKE.
AND WE MOVE QUICKLY TO MAKE IT
WIDELY AVAILABLE INCLUDING TO
THOUSANDS OF CONVENIENT TESTS TO
TREAT SITES WHERE YOU CAN GET
TESTED, AND IF YOU NEED IT,
PAXLOVID IS AT THE READY RIGHT
THEN AND THERE WHEN YOU MAKE
YOUR VISIT.
AGAIN, GO TO COVID.GOV TO FIND
WHERE TESTS AND TREAT SITES ARE
NEAR YOU.
HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE -- WHEN
MY PREDECESSOR GOT COVID, HE HAD
TO GET HELICOPTERED TO WALTER
REED MEDICAL CENTER.
HE WAS SEVERELY ILL.
THANKFULLY HE RECOVERED.
WHEN I GOT COVID, I WORKED FROM
UPSTAIRS IN THE WHITE HOUSE AND
THE OFFICES UPSTAIRS AND FOR THE
THE DIFFERENCE IS VACCINATIONS
OF COURSE.
BUT ALSO NEW TOOLS FREE TO ALL
AND WIDELY AVAILABLE.
YOU DON'T NEED TO BE PRESIDENT
TO GET THESE TOOLS TO USE FOR
YOUR DEFENSE.
IN FACT THE SAME BOOSTER SHOTS,
THE SAME AT HOME TESTS, THE SAME
TREATMENT THAT I GOT IS
AVAILABLE TO YOU.
MY ADMINISTRATION MADE SURE THAT
ALL AMERICANS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, FROM ALL WALKS OF LIFE,
HAVE FREE ACCESS TO THOSE TOOLS.
COVID WAS KILLING THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS A DAY WHEN I GOT HERE.
THAT ISN'T THE CASE ANYMORE.
YOU CAN LIVE WITHOUT FEAR BY
DOING WHAT I DID, GET BOOSTED,
GET TESTED AND GET TREATMENT.
AT THE SAME TIME MY
ADMINISTRATION REMAINS VIGILANT.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE THE TOOLS TO
KEEP YOU FROM GETTING SEVERELY
ILL OR DYING FROM COVID.
BUT WE'RE NOT STOPPING THERE.
EARLIER THIS WEEK WE HAD A
CONFERENCE AT THE WHITE HOUSE
FOR ABOUT THE NEXT GENERATION OF
VACCINES WITH A GOAL OF KEEPING
PEOPLE FROM GETTING SICK IN THE
FIRST PLARCE, GETTING COVID AT
ALL.
LET ME CLOSE WITH THIS.
OVER THE PAST 18 MONTHS, MY
ADMINISTRATION HAS LEFT NO STONE
UNTURNED IN OUR FIGHT AGAINST
THIS PANDEMIC.
NONE.
WE BROUGHT DOWN DEATHS BY NEARLY
90% SINCE I TOOK OFFICE BECAUSE
OF THE HELP OF ALL THE PEOPLE IN
THIS ROSE GARDEN.
BUSINESSES AND SCHOOLS
RESPONDED.
GRANDPARENTS ARE HUGGING THEIR
G
GRANDKIDS AGAIN.
WEDDINGS AND CELEBRATIONS ARE
HAPPENING IN PERSON AGAIN.
SO LET'S KEEP EMERGING FROM THE
DARK WITH HOPE AND LIGHT FROM
WHAT CAN COME.
GET VACCINATED IF YOU HAVEN'T
ALREADY.
AND NOW GET BOOSTED.
ORDER YOUR FREE TEST AND IF YOU
GET SICK, AND TEST POSITIVE,
SEEK TREATMENT.
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THESE
LIFE-SAVING TOOLS.
WE HAVE MORE OF THESE TOOLS THAN
WE EVER HAD BEFORE.
AND TO MY FRIENDS IN CONGRESS,
LET'S KEEP INVESTING IN THESE
TOOLS.
VACCINATIONS, TREATMENTS, TESTS.
AND MORE SO WE CAN HELP MAKE
THEM AVAILABLE TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ON A PERMANENT BASIS.
LET'S GET MOVING.
WHEN I SAY PERMANENT BASIS, AS
HON
LONG AS THEY ARE NEEDED.
LET'S KEEP MOVING FORWARD
SAFELY.
GOD BLESS YOU ALL.
AND NOW I GET TO GO BACK TO THE
OVAL OFFICE.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
>> DEFINITELY NOT TAKING
QUESTIONS AS HE WALKED BACK INTO
THE OVAL OFFICE.
KAITLAN COLLINS IS STANDING BY
WITH US WHO WAS IN THE ROSE
GARDEN.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS HE IS FEELING
GREAT, SAYS HE GOT THROUGH IT
WITHOUT ANY FEAR.
>> Reporter: AND THE PRESIDENT
USED THIS APPEARANCE, HIS FIRST
ONE SINCE LAST THURSDAY OF
COURSE WHEN HE TESTED POSITIVE
FOR COVID-19 AS HE WAS ON HIS
WAY FOR A FULL DAY OF EVENTS TO
TOUT THE TREATMENTS THAT HE'S
GOTTEN, THE VACCINES, BOOSTER
SHOTS, PAXLOVID SAYING THAT HE
DOES BELIEVE THAT HELPED HIM
HAVE A MILD CASE AND EVEN
INVOKED HIS PREDECESSOR'S CASE
WITH COVID-19 WHEN PRESIDENT
TRUMP TESTED POSITIVE AND WE SAW
HIM MAKE THE TRIP FROM THE
RESIDENCE OF THE WHITE HOUSE TO
MARINE ONE SO HE COULD GO TO
WALTER REED HOSPITAL WHERE HE
WAS THERE FOR SEVERAL DAYS.
SO HE TALKED ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCE IN THAT, THE
DIFFERENCE INM THE TREATMENTS AD
WHY HE HAD SUCH A DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCE THAN HIS PREDECESSOR
DID.
SO HE WAS PUSHING FOR THAT
TELLING PEOPLE IF THEY ARE OVER
50 YEARS OLD, THEY NEED TO GET A
BOOSTER.
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER THEY
WOULD SOON BE AUTHORIZED FOR
THOSE UNDER 50.
SO USING HIS OWN DIAGNOSIS TO
PUSH THAT MESSAGE.
HE DID NOT ANSWER QUESTIONS.
AND THERE ARE MANY OF THEM
ESPECIALLY THIS WEEK AS IT HAS
REALLY BECOME THIS MOMENT OF
TRUTH FOR THE WHITE HOUSE ON THE
ECONOMY WITH THE NUMBERS
EXPECTED TODAY, POTENTIAL
INTEREST RATE HIKE FROM THE
FEDERAL RESERVE, SECOND QUARTER
GDP NUMBERINGS COMING OUT  TOMORROW
HE SAID HE'S GOING BACK TO WORK
IT"S GREAT TO SEE YOU KAITLAN. THANK YOU SO MUCH